côté diplomatie les ministres européens
des Affaires étrangères sont réunis au
Luxembourg un seul but pour eux
accentuer l'aide à l'Ukraine ça passe
par plus de livraison d'armes mais aussi
par la formation de dizaines de milliers
de soldats pierre Benazet bonjour on
vous retrouve à Bruxelles les 27 ont
approuvé la formation de 15000 soldats
Ukrainiens c'est ça
et tu es préparé déjà on sait que les
européens depuis cet été précisément
avec émancé à mettre sur pied des plans
pour former des soldats Ukrainiens on
sait qu'il y a évidemment d'une part la
préoccupation d'aider l'Ukraine à avoir
des troupes plus combatives et plus
efficaces en regard des techniques de
combat et des techniques stratégiques
des armées occidentales mais les armées
ukrainiennes ont prouvé selon les
Européens leur capacité d'adaptation
d'adaptation et leur capacité d'action
en revanche ces formations sont aussi en
très grande partie liées aux armements
de pointe qui ont été fournis par les
pays européens ces armements de pointe
doivent être servis par des militaires
par des soldats qui ont reçu des
formations très spécifiques qui sont
quelquefois très compliqué à servir et
donc ces missions de formation c'était
évidemment une des priorités pour les
Européens sachant qu'ils ne sont pas les
seuls évidemment à se lancer dans
l'émission de formation
même si ici l'Allemagne et l'Ukraine
l'Allemagne et la Pologne pardon ont
décidé en quelque sorte de prendre un
peu un roll moteur en proposant
d'accueillir des états majeurs de ces
missions de formation ce seront tous les
pays volontaires dans l'Union européenne
qui devrait former des militaires
Ukrainiens en dehors de l'union entre
européenne on sait que le Royaume-Uni
par exemple a déjà lui formé 10000
militaires Ukrainiens merci beaucoup
pour ces éléments pierre vénez à
Bruxelles